>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
OH THE DRAMA.
THE CHAUVIN TRIAL IS OVER.
OFFICER DEREK CHAUVIN WAS
CONVICTED YESTERDAY ON ALL
COUNT.
THE TRIAL WENT ON FOR MORE THAN
A MONTH AND THE TESTIMONY WAS
COMPLEX AND TECHNICAL.
AT THE CENTER OF THE CASE THERE
WAS ONE PIECE OF RELEVANT
EVIDENCE.
IT WAS A VIDEOTAPE OF GEORGE
FLOYD'S DEATH IN THE STREET OF
MINNEAPOLIS.
IF YOU HAVE NOT SEEN THE TAPE
RECENTLY, IT'S EVERY BIT AS
SHOCKING AS THE DAY IT WAS SHOT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT GEORGE FLOYD
KNOWS ON SOME LEVEL HE WILL DIE
AND HE DOES DIE.
IT'S CRUSHING.
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN SAW IT AND
WERE HORRIFIED.
MANY DECIDED THAT OFFICER
CHAUVIN MUST HAVE COMMITTED AN
ACT OF CRIMINAL BRUTALITY.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THE
JURY YESTERDAY CONCLUDED THE
SAME THING WANT THE IMAGES IN
THAT TAPE SEEM TO TELL THE WHOLE
STORY.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT EVEN IF NO
ONE OUTSIDE OF THE COURTROOM IN
MINNEAPOLIS HAD EVER SEEN THAT
TAPE JUST THE JURY IT IS
POSSIBLE DEREK CHAUVIN WOULD
STILL BE CONVICTED.
THE TAPE IS THAT POWERFUL.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE ABOUT IT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
THE GEORGE FLOYD VIDEO WENT
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IT BECAME THE CENTERPIECE OF
A NEW POLITICAL MOVEMENT.
POLITICAL ACTORS HARNESSED THE
EMOTION OVER THAT VIDEO AND
FLOYD'S DEATH TO CONTROL THE
COUNTRY AND CHANGE IT FOREVER.
THIS IS THE KEY OF WHAT WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT.
IN THE LAST MONTH SOME OF THESE
SAME PEOPLE WENT FURTHER THAN
THAT.
THEY WORKED TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF DEREK CHAUVIN'S
TRIAL.
THAT'S ONE THING WE CAN NEVER
ALLOW NO MATTER HOW WE FEEL
ABOUT A SPECIFIC CASE.
CIVILIZED COUNTIES HAVE
IMPARTIAL SYSTEMS OF JUSTICE.
THEY DEMAND THAT EVERY CITIZEN
IS HELD TO PRECISELY THE SAME
STANDARD UNDER THE LAW AS EVERY
OTHER CITIZEN IS.
THAT AA -- APPLIES NO MATTER THE
ALLEGED CRIME.
CIVILIZED COUNTRIES DON'T
TOLERATE JURY INTIMIDATION.
YOU SEE IT AND STOP IT.
EVER UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT IS MOB RULE.
AMERICA USED TO THRIVE HARD TO
BE LIKE THAT.
-- STRIVE.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES THREW HIS BACKING
BEHIND DEREK CHAUVIN'S
PROSECUTION EVEN AS THE JURY WAS
STILL DELIBERATING THE CASE.
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL MEMBER
OF THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
TELL ANGRY PEOPLE THEY SHOULD
ACT OUT IN VIOLENCE IS THE JURY
ACQUITS.
WE WATCHED MINNEAPOLIS CONCEDE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE TRIAL BEFORE DEREK CHAUVIN'S
LAWYER COULD SUM UP HIS CASE.
AND WE SAW THUGS THREATEN
A DEFENSE WITNESS WITH DEATH.
THEY SMEARED PIG BLOOD ON THE
DOOR OF WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
HIS HOUSE AND GOT AWAY WITH IT.
THESE WERE TERRIFYING ACT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU THINK
DEREK CHAUVIN IS GUILTY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU VOTED
FOR.
MOBS TRYING TO INFLUENCE THIS
TRIAL SHOULD SHOCK AND HORRIFY
AT LEAST AS MUCH AS THE GEORGE
FLOYD VIDEO DID.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF A COUNTRY
MOVING BACKWARD AT HIGH SPEED.
THE STRANGE THING IS THAT MOST
PEOPLE DIDN'T SEEM SHOCKED OR
UPSET BY ANY OF THIS.
THEY SEEMED RELIEVED BY THE
VERDICT.
THEY WATCHED THE TROOPS IN THE
STREETS AND UNDERSTOOD WHAT AN
ACQUITTAL WOULD MEAN.
THEY BELIEVED THAT A CONVICTION
JUSTIFIED OR NOT WOULD BUY THE
COUNTRY PEACE.
MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT SO INCLUDING
MANY REPUBLICANS.
SOME SAID SO.
IF WE OBEYED MAXINE WATERS AND
IGNORED THE PIG BLOOD THE CHAOS
WOULD END.
AFTER 11 MINUTES OF VIOLENCE
FROM BLM, AMERICANS DECIDED TO
PAY THE RANSOM.
DEREK CHAUVIN HAD TO SACRIFICE
FOR THE SINS OF A NATION.
ON TELEVISION THEY TOLD US THIS
WAS THE CASE.
SOUTH AMERICA ON TRIAL.
-- AMERICA IS ON TRIAL.
IT'S ALL OF US, OUR HISTORY,
CULTURE AND SYSTEM.
WE INTERNALIZED THAT.
BUT WE WERE FOOLISH TO GO ALONG
WITH IT.
A WISE COUNTRY STANDS ON
PRINCIPLES.
IT PUTS DOWN MOBS.
IT DOES NOT OBEY MOBS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT DEMANDS
YOU FOLLOW, THEY DEMAND MORE.
NOW THEY ARE DEMANDING MORE.
THE TWO MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES REACTING TO
YESTERDAY'S VERDICT.
NO ONE SHOWED THAT RACE OR SKIN
COLOR PLAYED ANY ROLE IN THE
DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD.
BUT THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
THE DETAILS OF THE CASE.
THEIR PLAN IS TO USE THE TRIAL
THE WAY THEY USED GEORGE FLOYD.
>> A MEASURE OF JUSTICE IS NOT
THE SAME AS EQUAL JUSTICE.
THIS VERDICT BRINGS US A STEP
CLOSER AND THE FACT IS, WE STILL
HAVE WORK TO DO.
WE STILL MUST REFORM THE SYSTEM.
>> NO ONE SHOULD BE ABOVE THE
LAW.
TODAY'S VERDICT EXTEND THAT
MESSAGE, BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IT CAN'T STOP HERE.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WE MUST REFORM THE SYSTEM.
THEY DON'T SAY HOW BUT THEIR
INTENT IS OBVIOUS.
IT TURNS THAT DEREK CHAUVIN'S
CONVICTION WAS NOT THE END OF
THE REVOLUTION.
IT WAS JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE
REVOLUTION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HIMSELF
ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY THAT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO FLOYD'S DEATH
OVERSEEN BY A RACIST CLARK IS
ON-GOING.
IT'S ON-GOING?
DIDN'T WE JUST HAVE A MONTH LONG
TRIAL THAT PRESENTED ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE?
YES, BUT ONCE AGAIN THAT WAS
JUST THE START.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT NEXT?
IT'S HARD TO KNOW BUT THERE ARE
SIGNS.
HERE ARE BLM ACTIVISTS
CELEBRATING THE VERDICT LAST
NIGHT IN NEW YORK.
GEORGE FLOYD DIED 1200 MILES
FROM NEW YORK IN A DIFFERENT
REGION.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW GEORGE FLOYD
AND PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH HIS
TRIAL.
BUT JUSTICE FOR GEORGE FLOYD IS
NOT THE POINT.
EVERY ENDING ETHNIC CONFLICT IS
THE POINT.
LISTEN.
>> [BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> WE DON'T WANT YOU HERE!
>> WE DON'T YOU WANT HERE.
>> WE DON'T YOUR [BLEEP].
>> [BLEEP].
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WITH THE WRONG
SKIN COLOR HAVE TO LEAVE NEW
YORK CITY AND THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO OWN RESTAURANTS.
PEOPLE DIDN'T USE TO TALK LIKE
THIS IN PUBLIC.
WHETHER THEY DID THEY WERE
SCOLDED AT THE VERY LEAST.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A MULTI-ETHNIC
NATION HOLD TOGETHER IF PEOPLE
SCREAM THAT ON THE STREET.
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT NOW?
IT GETS RESULTS.
RADICALISM AND VIOLENCE WORKS.
THAT'S THE LESSON.
WE HAVE TAUGHT THEM THAT LESSON.
HERE'S ONE BLM ACTIVIST WHO SAYS
IT OUT LOUD.
>> IT WAS A MIXTURE OF VIOLENT
AND NON-VIOLENT PROTESTS THAT
YIELDED THIS RESULT.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
AMERICA DOESN'T LISTEN TO US
WHEN WE MARCH PEACEFULLY.
I AM NOT SAYING PEOPLE WILL BE
BACK IN THE STREET.
BUT AMERICA MUST KNOW IF YOU
CONTINUE TO ALLOW US TO BE
MURDERED IN THE STREETS WITHOUT
JUSTICE, WE WILL RAISE HELL IN
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: SO VIOLENCE GETS
RESULTS.
THAT'S A THREAT OF COURSE BUT
IT'S TRUE.
WHEN YOU BURN CITIES YOU GET
WHAT YOU WANT.
YOU GET CORPORATE HAND OUT US
AND GET THE INJURE VERDICTS YOU
DEMANDED.
RIOTERS KNOW